e questo il suono che mi piace sentire
la mattina le sirene
siamo sulle gru kevin siamo tornati
perché come tutti sapete ho fatto la
terza parte quindi questo però mancano
tutte le altre anche la porta la quinta
o sesta che non ho mai fatto in vita mia
e quindi direi di andare per la quarta o
raga io ci ho giocato un botto sto gioco
non ho mai fatto nulla è la madonna
maronna roux carmen un attimo un attimo
per cortesia
[Musica]
abbiamo già perso in partenza va bene
the course of the lei la maledizione
nell'arco director scatto direi che
possiamo andare avanti anche perché non
è successo niente ancora di particolare
quindi che cosa nostra sono galline
tranquilli out the house
uomini nudi
anzi donne nude aiuto che non sarebbe
malissimo e sarà attaccate ecco magari
lui no lui è un gioco di gambe vento beh
sono l'unico che non sta capendo un
cazzo di quello che sta succedendo i rei
di fare le star sono perché il suo nome
sono partito male prova beh io non ho
capito veramente che cosa devo fare il
suo gioco cioè dove non ho capito
entrate subito tutti grazie prima è
passato uno zombie a caso madonna ruzgar
aiuto aiuto aiuto
ok e in tutto questo quindi bastava far
entrare tutti nel camper all'inizio ci
siamo salvati pletora ai a lui sono
aiuto c'è un pacco e dove son finito
ok ho tratto proiettili del fucile bene
se riuscissi a ritornare indietro uomini
nudi e va beh ragazzi costumi
[Musica]
raga ma che è sciocco delle palle il
camper si è fermato non ci abbiamo più
la benza l'obiettivo visto gioco e
trovare la benzina per far ripartire il
campo alla benzina si trova dentro la
slough ko e su quella di prima quante
cose ci sono d'affari ma scusatemi è
tutto un tentativo per recuperare il gas
in tutto questo va bene se io entro ed
esco dalle forti in periodo di aver
vantaggio eccola
[Musica]
porcaro ho sbagliato tasto
le epoche gesù no non è vero
minchia aragon sbagliato tasto e
raccoglie la benza invece non riuscite
school plummer sbagliato tasto e
riproviamo ci scherzavo stavo scherzavo
quello zio ha intenzione di venire fin
qua no spero di no perché ovviamente
sarebbe difficilissimo sono come
proseguo madonna veramente lega ma
sensei
[Musica]
quasi mi conviene non me la tocca quella
nel camper vero per curiosità è ok
mai mai mai aveva più veloce entra
e lui può entrarci però io no
parolisi va bè ragazzi almeno non ci
sono più i maiali proviamo a vedere se
riesco a salvarmi con l'ultima
divertente finora basta seguire le porte
sfondate dovrei ritornato loro prima
perfetto
ok prendi la prendi la rai che non mi
ricordo da due porca eva morta porca non
mi ricordavo dov'ero arrivato lì che è
difficilissimo regalo giuro pro ci
riproviamo dai no no no mi son
dimenticato dimenticato
[Musica]
sempre a mia madre quando tornavo cui
due di matematica a casa ma anche qua
c'è una cosa di gas
scusate ma allora scusato scemo io ma
che mi fanno arrivare fino a un tot
quindi non trovarne di più
a giudicare da quanto fatto di strada
devo trovare almeno quattro sentimento
vai veloce
noi del neri che le vede n se c'e verso
non riesco a farci una riga impossibile
niente ripartiamo dentro siamo partite
[Musica]
te lo dico io ma quanti metri faccio e
fin qua o trovarne almeno almeno altre
tre regalarle inoltre 3 gen tenuta
perché io sbaglio cambio personaggio mai
salve
devo porcaro che jobs che vai se vivo
scherzavo ora era appellata ricarica
veloce come sono caduto quasi clusane e
chiuso la porta park a bacca nera che
lasciamo là
andiamo avanti
[Musica]
praga no c'è veramente manchi a
sbloccare la porta bene a saperlo prima
magari no ma niente alla rivista la
fanno la famiglia magari collega la gara
devo farlo molto prima e successo regala
giusto che sta succedendo trapano pure
voi corrente pezzi di milan inter mi sa
di sì perché aiuto
quanta gente con l'attacco a tutti
attacca ammazzato tutti ammazzato tutti
il coso ama quindi mi sono lavato
perfetto ma quindi il tipo vestito da
maiale ammazzatutti grande mica buono a
sapersi non avrà una supposta roba
candelabro ok anche questa applicazione
non so visto lì anche questo interiore
ecco se riuscissi ad ammazzare sto tizio
l'altra tanica in teoria equa destra
problema è che
tutto molto chiaro
questo gioco è l'apoteosi del jump
scarcella roba incredibile
adesso mi partono tutte qua dentro così
per presa per il culo cosa sto vedendo
ritardo ma io un vecchio va bene basta è
data fuoco il vecchio fuoco stata fuoco
anch'io una doccia
niente scherzava premorto vecchio che
gioco strano mio dio
tra tutti i giochi strani del mondo ok
beh meno tutti di sci placca faccia
spacco tutto sono lega adesso finito ei
va beh ok no no no no no no regolamento
non posso pavia via via via sono uscito
non so come ho fatto ma sono uscito bene
ma manca l'altra che c'è sempre qua
dentro
bastano due die che c'è crisi fanno che
bastano
in teoria dovrebbe andare più avanti
prima almeno in teoria pregava che si
che cosa stai cercando esattamente ok
come se ti fermi ogni 3x2 cucina arrivi
manca brescia arrivi no ho sbagliato ho
sbagliato non è vero va beh ti dopo
almeno video posto le date anche fuoco
almeno una è morta vpn raga siamo
arrivati a due record dei record
vabbè ragazzi per oggi basta così è
veramente impossibile riuscire mai a
finire anche un livello di sto gioco
però almeno ci proviamo
bravi gli sia piaciuto ragazzi come se
vi è piaciuto momento mi piace anche la
lista civitas chiziane se non sapere si
scateni ci vediamo al prossimo video dai
ragazzi
[Musica]